nice ready these two people are not
married and they're going to have
premarital sex do you want
have been more do you want to go now it
is time to honor the breasts of the
women in the room I would like you to
turn to the person next to you hi is it
possible he could do a three-way I've
never done a three-way why are you in
this class you seem so together ah yeah
I really think you should come over I
won't have hot sex with someone who's
really nice to me let's just go have sex
in my office no I've been dating this
guy for two years I love you as his
friend and as a sexual partner
what love why do you always call me a
dirty little [ __ ] ah just because maybe
you're you're jealous that are more
successful than you why are we sitting
around talking about how sad our lives
are you're right we should be talking
about how great we are I want there to
be a lot of blood in this scene why is
the woman who enjoys sex always have to
die in horror films maybe she could
fight back I think that's probably the
worst idea ever mind her life so but I
can't do that one we talk about pleasing
men but what about pleasing us they
could I leave my laundry here get it on
Thursday
you want me to do your laundry while you
date other women you should do your
laundry yeah you are so hot like really
hot
let's make a pact to be with good guys
only guys who treat us great like we
deserve well there's this guy he asked
me all these super attractive you should
go for it
move over there's a new skank in town
having sex with me is a religious
experience I like you strip thank you
she's a good writer I want you to do my
laundry now in my life
boss smear on small kind of turn me on
looks all I want to have sex with you
okay no good guys only cook guys guys
only jerk sex no drift sex
you
you